inciso se encuentra una solución
particular de w igual la w de té a la
ecuación diferencial derivada de w con
respecto al tiempo igual a un 25 años de
w menos 300 con la condición inicial w
en 0 es igual a mil 400 mil 400
toneladas porque las unidades que
teníamos eran toneladas bien seguramente
tú me vas a decir oye sal eso está muy
difícil como pueden poner una ecuación
diferencial si yo no he tomado el curso
de ecuaciones diferenciales yo solamente
ese cálculo y el curso para presentar
los exámenes tipo a ve que puedo yo
hacer para responder éste esta pregunta
y yo te voy a contestar en tu curso de
cálculo abt tuvieron que haber enseñado
cómo resolver ecuaciones diferenciales
por el método de separación de variables
si de plano no tienes ni idea de lo que
estoy hablando entonces lo vamos a ver
aquí no te preocupes yo tengo la
derivada de w con respecto al tiempo
igual a un 25 ago de w menos 300 el
método que voy a utilizar es el método
de separación de variables
aquí yo tengo a mi w yo lo que necesito
es resolver esta ecuación diferencial y
encontrar una función w que dependa del
tiempo y bueno la idea es pasar todo lo
que tengan que ver con w de un lado de
la ecuación y todo lo que tenga que ver
con el tiempo del otro lado de la
ecuación entonces qué pasa si yo
multiplico todo por uno entre el doble
un menos 300 pues me queda uno entre
w300 que multiplica la derivada de w con
respecto al tiempo y del otro lado doble
un menos 300 entre 2 la unión 300 se va
y solamente me queda 1 entre 25 bien y
ahora qué pasa si multiplico todo por dt
entonces multiplicó por aquí y por acá
por dt y me queda del lado izquierdo de
la ecuación se van los diferenciales dt
y entonces solamente obtengo diferencial
de w / w 2 300 y del otro lado pues me
queda un 25 ambos diferencial de t
entonces vamos a ponerlo 1 / w nos 300
diferencial de w es igual
todo esto diferencial de w es igual a un
25 lo voy a poner de otro color por
diferencial del tiempo y ahora hay que
tomar la integral de ambos lados y si
podemos tomar esta integral debido a que
tenemos uno entre doble unos 300 por el
diferencial de w igual a 1 entre 25 por
el diferencial de t es decir tenemos una
función por el diferencial de w es igual
a otra función por el diferencial de t y
si tomamos todas las sumas de cada uno
de los diferenciales de w y todas las
sumas de todos los diferenciales de t es
decir de todos los pequeños cambios de w
y todos los pequeños cambios de t
entonces esta igualdad se mantiene por
lo tanto la integral si la podemos tomar
a pues bueno vamos a ver quién es la
integral de 1 / w menos 300 por
diferencial de w
voy a tomar una nueva función
o como doble un menos 300 seguramente
esto ya lo puedes ser en tu cabeza pero
si no lo sabes hacer vamos a hacerlo con
calma tienes la derivada de v con
respecto a w pues bueno la derivada de
eu con respecto a w pues es la derivada
de w que es 1 y la derivada de 300 que
cero sea 1 bien entonces ahora qué va a
pasar si yo multiplico ambos lados por
la diferencial de w me va a quedar
diferencial de eeuu es igual a
diferencial de w entonces voy a escribir
esta integral con términos de v me va a
quedar la integral de 1 entre 1 por la
diferencial de 1 por la diferencia de
abu la diferencial de w son lo mismos y
r guardan w menos 300 solamente puesto
todo lo que ya sé y ahora si una de las
integrales más importantes que hay y que
hay que saberse de memoria es la
integral de 1 entre un diferencial de
buques el logaritmo natural del valor
absoluto de un pero uno era igual a w
menos 300 entonces vamos a ponerlo
logaritmo natural de w menos 300 y ya
tengo la primera integral la integral
del lado izquierdo entonces 1
de unos 300 diferencial de w de hecho a
veces puede ser muy fácil la función
doble unos 300 su derivada es uno y por
lo tanto me queda el logaritmo natural
de el valor absoluto de doble o menos
300 entonces vamos a ponerlo aquí la
integral del lado izquierdo es igual a
logaritmo natural del valor absoluto de
w menos 300 y bueno del otro lado que
tengo la integral de 1 entre 25 de
diferencia al dt y esto es algo muy
sencillo es una vez integrada es muy
básica es porque la constante salida
integral y solamente me queda la
integral desde que esté entonces le
queda 1 entre 25 por teo de entre 25 ya
esto hay que sumarle una constante de
integración recuerden que cuando
integramos aparece una constante la
podemos poner de un lado de otro de
hecho imagínense que la ponemos de un
lado y de otro recuerden que si yo tengo
una constante a un lado y del otro y al
final yo paso del otro lado la constante
pues me quedaría hacer dos menos uno que
es un hace tres casi nada es una
constante recuerden que la suma y la
resta de constantes es una constante
entonces solamente es necesario ponerlo
de un lado l
bueno ahora ya tengo esta igualdad
expresada aquí y yo lo que tengo que
hacer son dos cosas uno escribirá a w
como función del tiempo y dos saber
cuánto vale esta constante con mis
condiciones iniciales entonces primero
voy a sacar el valor de la constante
para esto voy a utilizar las condiciones
iniciales que me daban acá arriba las
condiciones iniciales decían que cuando
que ya sabemos que w de cero es igual a
1.400 toneladas
w de cero es igual a 1.400 toneladas y
bueno esto lo voy a utilizar ahorita
porque porque yo voy a sustituir a w ya
el tiempo para obtener la constante
logaritmo natural de 1400 w vale 1400
menos 300 todo esto en valor absoluto es
igual al tiempo que vale 0 por las
condiciones iniciales 0 entre 25 0 + una
constante y ahora sí logaritmo natural
de 1.409 300 que es mil 100 del valor
absoluto de 1100 es igual a la constante
para de hecho 1100 pues ya su valor
absoluto es el mismo entonces la
constante es igual a logaritmo natural
de 1100 jazz en el valor absoluto porque
pues es necesario cargar con él y bueno
ya tengo la constante ahora lo que
quiero es intentar escribir a w como
función del tiempo ya con esto acabaría
este problema entonces vamos a intentar
hacerlo el logaritmo natural del valor
absoluto de w menos 300 y ahora que lo
pienso no es necesario poner
forzosamente el valor absoluto porque w
es una función creciente siempre es
creciente y además empieza en 1400
entonces 1.400 nuevos 300 siempre va a
ser un número positivo y a partir de ahí
que crezca mi función cualquier número
mayor de 1.400 nuevos 300 también va a
ser un número positivo entonces yo creo
que podemos que tener valor absoluto y
poner mejor logaritmo natural de w menos
300 es igual a
un tv entre 25 más la constante por la
constante es el logaritmo natural de
1100 bueno pero estamos atrás de w lo
que queremos es a w como función del
tiempo entonces lo que me estorba es el
logaritmo natural para deshacernos del
lugar y tú natural lo que yo voy a hacer
es agarrar la función exponencial de
ambos lados de la igualdad entonces me
va a quedar elevado el logaritmo natural
de w300 es igual a elevado a la t entre
25 más el logaritmo natural de 1100 y
bueno ahora me estorba esto entonces voy
a borrarlo si para tener más espacio voy
a borrar esto bien y ahora que me queda
la exponencial con el logaritmo se van
son funciones inversas por lo tanto se
cancelan y solamente me queda w un menos
trescientos entonces es exponencial y
logaritmo vámonos de aquí y me queda
solamente doble un menos 300
y del otro lado que me va a quedar
elevado a la t entre 25 más del
logaritmo natural de 1100 es lo mismo
que a la de entre 25 x
al logaritmo natural de 1100 esto es por
las leyes de los exponentes recuerden
que a la b x al hacer lo mismo que a la
p más c entonces estos dos son iguales
bueno ahora ya casi tengo w lo único que
me estorba primero es el logaritmo
natural de 1100 es ni más ni menos que
1100 el logaritmo otra vez se va con
exponencial entonces se cancele me
quedan 1100 entonces w menos 300 es
igual a 1100 que multiplica
a la t entre 25 y ahora si estoy a punto
de despejar a w me estorba el 300 voy a
pasar del otro lado sumando 1100
alarte entre 25 más 300 y aquí lo tienen
hemos resuelto esta ecuación diferencial
con una solución particular al obtener
el valor de la constante y darse cuenta
que no era necesario saber todas las
herramientas difíciles de ecuaciones
solamente necesitamos un poco de
conocimiento de cálculo y saber integrar